Um, let's go next to our caller from the six
46 area code.
Who's calling today from six, four, six.
Hi, David.
It's just me.
Yes it is.
Hi, I'm Ben.
I'm from Chappaqua New York, about half a
mile from the Clintons as a matter of fact,
of course.
So, yeah, so I'm 17 years old and um, I'm
very politically active.
I really have been into politics since probably
even before 2016.
You know, my parents and all that.
And I've noticed that a lot of other guys
my age come from pretty left-wing families,
but they've sort of gotten absorbed into this
sort of libertarian, borderline Trump right
wing ideology based on, I feel like a lot
of the media, more independent media such
as Michael Knowles, Ben Shapiro, Steven Crowder,
Ken state gun girl, Prager U.
And I feel like these people have created
this sort of cynicism towards certain social
aspects such as feminism or LGBT rights.
And I feel like personally I've gotten sucked
in a little bit too, and I'm worried that
this may actually help Trump win again.
Like, you know, I for example, in 2016 I was
the guy yelling at Bernie was too far.
Right?
But now honestly it's going to be my first
primary voting and I'm probably gonna vote
for Joe Biden.
All right.
But hold on a second.
Let's see if we can break these things down
a little bit.
So, uh, so I take it that now you think Bernie
is too far left.
You used to think he was too far.
Right now.
You think he's too far left on?
What issue is Bernie too far left in your
mind?
[inaudible]
with me.
I feel like I've gotten absorbed again.
Again, again, I say I feel like he's targeting
a different audience in this election.
So who's he targeting
in 2016 in inner city voters as opposed to
the country as a whole, you know, rural middle
American voters that ended up voting for Trump,
which is what part of which really got me
in.
Got me into him.
But so hold on a second, we're skipping a
lot of stuff through.
What policy do you feel Bernie is targeting
inner city voters rather than rural voters?
What policy?
I feel like he's now turning from, I think
yes, he's still a lot of, there's a lot of
the old Bernie in there about it's wall street,
it's wall street, but I feel like there's
still a lot of, Oh, Trump's a racist.
Trump's a racist as opposed to then saying
that, uh, as opposed to saying that if policy
is inefficient, I feel like he's trying to
get younger millennial kind of got millennial
voters really hepped up as opposed to
how's it Bernie been doing both though?
I mean, hasn't Bernie been saying this?
This is, this is this thing that Trump said
that's just racist calling, you know, Elizabeth
Warren Pocahontas or whatever.
But then Bernie seems very policy centric.
He's talking about here's why Trump's trade
ideas don't work.
Here's why Trump's ideas on healthcare don't
work.
Here's how Trump's geopolitical and foreign
policy ideas don't work.
I mean, I'm just not seeing that.
Okay, so you said that he's pointed out that
Trump has said racist things.
Who hasn't?
Joe Biden has pointed that out as well.
And you say you like Joe Biden.
So what is it that Bernie's doing that Joe
isn't, that you feel is turning you off?
Another, another thing that I remember, I
actually saw on your show is his affiliation
with Linda Sarsour and close relationship
with AOC and Newhart.
Omar, you know, I'm Jewish.
I've visited as a real, it's a very big part
of my identity and I feel that, I think I'm
not wandering people that says BDS is not
okay.
Of course it's free speech, but publicly affiliate
associating yourselves with personally I feel
upon Nomar but I think that
Ben, you're breaking up terribly, but listen,
if you can still hear me, I agree with you
that Bernie should have no association with
Linda Sarsour, but I want you to, I want to
point out to you because you know we're examining
your beliefs here.
Your first argument was that you believe Bernie
has shifted to targeting urban millennials
over rural voters and you don't like that.
And when I asked for examples, the one you
came up with is something that Joe Biden also
does and now you're shifting to something
else, which is you don't like Bernie's associations
with some people are.
Are you cognizant of the fact that the first
assertion you made, you haven't so far been
able to back up with any real good examples
that are unique to Bernie?
Yeah, I do understand that.
I feel like maybe I've just been listening
to him more lately or something, but I dunno.
I personally back in 2016 I saw him as this
sort of European like socialist and I, I've
just seen him talk more lately in the last
two or three years about certain issues like
women's rights, immigrant rights, which you
know I'm all for, but if a candidate is running
on those issues,
hold on a second.
Going to Ben.
Ben, let me ask you a question.
If I said to you, what is the, when you think
about Bernie's candidacy, what's the number
one issue you associate with Bernie?
You mean like problem I have with them or
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The number one political issue that is the
most important pillar of his platform.
What would you say it is?
I'd say is tackling big corporations and wall
street.
No, no, no, but the policy, hold on a second.
I know you know what it is.
What's the policy that is associated with
Bernie specifically?
That was the, the biggest issue for him in
2016 and remains the biggest issue, which
now everybody, Mo, many people have come around
to agree with him on
a wealth tax.
No, it's health care.
Okay.
I, I'm giving you the answer.
So listen, um, uh, Medicare for all right.
This is, this is to say that Bernie's candidacy
is based on women's rights.
Listen, Bernie's candidacy is of course predicated
on the idea that we need to treat people equally
under the law and equality of opportunity
and so on and so forth.
But Bernie's, Bernie is the, in my mind is
the healthcare guy, number one, and is the
inequality and corporate cronyism guy number
two.
Uh, I, I think maybe you're, you're, you know,
uh, it just seems as though, uh, you, you
have a bit of a inaccurate perception maybe
of what is, you can still not like Bernie.
You can still like Biden over Bernie.
I'm just not hearing from you what sound to
me like really well thought out reasons for
it.
And that's what concerns me
and to, and to be honest, I agree with you.
I think it's partially, you know that one
person, someone, a couple of weeks ago said
you should interview a Hunter Avalon.
You know, I was, let's just say I, I had some
issues.
I won a big award at school and was screamed
at and called a white CIS male.
And that I want it only because of that status,
which, okay, that's neither here nor there.
But that got me, you know, sucked into the
Hunter Avalon, Dennis Shapiro.
And I think that's turned me a bit cynical
on these issues.
Right.
So it sounds like maybe this personal experience
that you had, you are now projecting onto
Bernie Sanders, even though it may not be
based, in fact.
Is that possible, Ben?
Yeah, it's possible.
That's human nature.
Yeah.
Yup.
All right, Ben, listen, I'm glad that you
are willing to hear reason and to think through
these issues.
I appreciate you calling me today.
Of course.
Thank you.
All right.
We'll talk to you again, I hope.
Sorry to everybody I didn't get to that.
Does it for calls today, we will take calls
again and we'll talk to everybody next week.